*Sick, gravley voice* Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And welcome to Amateur Surgeon: Christmas Edition
Now I vaguely remember trying to play this game in the past
But I don't think I ever actually made a video out of it
So that's exactly what I'm going to be doing.
I've never really played these games
But I can only imagine that it functions in a similar way
*takes breath* that surgeon simulator does.
You're a surgeon, by the name of Doctor Alan Probe-
Oh shit *game screams*
*game dings as words pop up*
Oh
OH JEEZ
OH! OH GOD!
Oh okay!
Why did that have to happen?
(Reading dialogue) "Stupid North Pole! No one told me they had to drive on the wrong side of the sky here!
Hey, why are the presents everywhere? Is anybody here?
Oh, that guy in the tree looks bad. I wonder if my tools are- crash
Dammit! Oh well there must be loads of things around here that I can use."
(Commentating) Oh okay, we're going right into it. Alright
Nice... boobs? I think. Alright whatever.
So this is Amateur Surgeon.
It's a bit quiet in here
but good thing I've put in some Christmas music to lighten the mood. (Starts playing Christmas music to lighten the mood)
And also I'm very festive
because that's exactly how these twelve days of Christmas are gonna go.
So let's get started because I've got nothing better to do with my time.
(Reading dialogue) "What the hell are you doing?"
(Commentating) I- honestly I have no idea.(Reading dialogue) "Don't worry, I'm a surgeon!
If you get nervous while I'm working, just ask me to pause."
I can tell you about injuries or tools I'm using, okay?"
"Uhh! Deal."
"Okay! First I need to extract these items! I've only got this grabber, so hold still!"
(Commentating) Yeah that seems safe *game screams*
Sorry!
(Reading dialogue) "Once I'm done, I'll tape you up..."
(Commentating) Okaaay
Yeah this is kinda like a lot of surgeon games that I've played.
Kinda like that super- super uhh Wii game that I've played in the past oh my go- *game screams again*
(Reading dialogue) "and soothe the pain"?
(Commentating) Wait was I- did I miss something here? (the game is constantly screaming from Mark's messing up)
(Reading dialogue) "A wire? It looks like it's attached to something in your body! Maybe I can find out more if I zap it."
(Commentating) Yeah that's probably a good idea
*zapping noise*
(Reading dialogue) "That sounds like a bad idea!"
(Commentating) Yeah I'm kinda with you on that but I already did something. Sorry.
I dunno what's with the glowing lights
Oh you have- oh I know
Okay so using the duct tape
Something like that
Burn 'em?
Sorry!
Sorry!!
SORRY!!!
What am I- am I doing something wrong!?
Ohh okay
Alright I got this
okay
Then I burn it...
*Scream*
No?
*Scream again*
No?!
Well I'm fucking up royally here
I'm sorry buddy even though you were apparently just talking to me you're probably gonna die
Can't be helped
Dammit come on!
*game flat lines* WELP apparently it's discovered that I'm a very bad doctor
that likes to kill people
And nurse, would you kindly shut the fuck up and try to help me here instead of being a sack of shit that dies on me?!
Yeah I fucked up there but that's okay because I wasn't really ready to do anything
I was just gonna get on my way and try to fix this goddamn elf
oh I needed more taaaaape
Is that what I needed?
Oh
*Realization* Ooohhhhh
It wasn't clooosed enough
Ah! Soooothing
Oh that's nice! Oh that's real nice!
Oh I'm doing great!
Okay. Habooski!
Alright, does this help?
That didn't fucking help a goddamn thing.
What is that supposed to do?
Knife? Oh!
Ooooh
I got it. Ohhhh
UUUUUUH
Okay I'm getting the hang of it now
I'm getting the hang of this
Burn (x4) because for some reason this is a good idea
Blam blam balamba balamba my lanta
Alright. I'm going in? Wait why am I going in?! Nurse why am I going in?!
Oh that's not riiight
Oh that's not right at all
Eugh
That seems bad
Eugh. (Reading dialogue) "I'll use the drill, then trace the red section away..." (Commentating) What?
Oh this seems like a bad ide- well I fucked up that one
I have no idea what I'm doing *game flat lines*
My patient was burned alive? Why was his heart on fire and why was he able to talk to me if his heart was on fuckin' fire?!?!
Nurse why didn't you get me a magical goddamn patient?!
GODDAMN IT NURSE
SHUT THE FUCK UP NURSE
SHUD UB NURS
AMMA GODDAMN DOCTOR!!!!!
Alright let's try this again
oh no
oh no come on
come on live you bastard...
live!
Live you bastard!!
Live you basta- goddamn it damn it damn it damn it!!
Why's it fucking impossible?
Okay if the patient's burned alive then maybe there's some way to put out the fire.
OHHH that-that's amazing!
There's a-there's a fucking guy!
Oooooohhhh I didn't know that
Ohhh that's fuck- there's a guhduh- aaaahhhhh shit
hfueifirhfih fuckin'... ahh fuck
See I didn't-
I didn't know that
Ah burns are being caused by the fire
You put the fire out by sucking up blood and blowing it at it
Ohhh amma suck up this blood then I'm gonna blow it
Oh that's so smart the f-
Oh my god! The fire! It's out!
That's fucking incredible
Oh my god this is so much easier!
Than racing the fucking clock trying to do the other bullshit that I was doing
Oohh this is so much easier
Alright so now I got that
And then I fix it up with pixie dusk
And then I put that there and then I- fix this shit
Fuckin' carve this bullshit out of here
Fuckin' suck up the blood
Blast blood there
Put that out, pixie dust those
AHh there we go okay there we go I gotta get it in segments
Before I'm able to do this shit
This is easy
Because it's done!
Yessszzzzz
Oh my god that's so much easier now that I actually know what I'm supposed to be doing
I WAS SPENDING FOREVER ON THAT! NURSE WHY DIDN'T YOU FUCKING TELL MEEE!?!
WHHHYYYYY?
owwww
Well now that I know what I'm supposed to do
"What the hell are you doing?"
"Some crazy jerk on a sled pulled by a bunch of flying dogs leaped right out in front of me!"
"You idiot! Those are reindeer! That was Santa!"
"What are you talking about? Oh no..."
"Oh crap! I hit santa! Uh, so what do we do now?"
YAY
That fucking took forever
I'm gonna try to do one more mission
Mincer?
"Where's Santa? Is he okay?" "I think one of the flying dogs got sucked into my jet engines and he crashed"
"You killed one of the reindeer?"
"It might be alive! It's just over by the jets. Well, bits of it anyway"
"OH MY GOD! Mincer!! You have to save him!"
EUGH
MiI don't wanna save Mincer
Mincer looks like he's seen better days. Ohhh boy
OOHh I don't wanna do this(
"Guess I'll just have to piece this together as I go"
I guess I will then
Okay. How- HOW IS THERE HEART BREATHING
Oh god
Oh that's not good. Oh!
Okay
EEEEgh
GEEEgh
Is this thing gonna be alive after I'm done?
I don't think I wanna know that I have these magical powers
Oh boy
"if I don't have the right part, I'll just have to use a substitute"
Ayah!
Oh okay!
Oh!
Oh alright!
Oh
Okay
Alright
Ohh boy
Ohhh boy
h-h-how is this- how is this still alive?
eeeEEEEeee
This goes here, this goes there, that goes there, this goes over here
Yeesh
Nurse, you might want to look away for this one
Ohhh this dog's seen better days!
Oh it's a bad day for this doggy
We missing something? It's a hidey hole. There it is.
Okay got it!
Whooooo. Oh boy. I dunno if I wanna be a part of this
This seems like something that's a diabolical experiment from hell
And I don't think I want- oooh
I don't wanna know where that goes (I think we  all know what he meant by that hehe....)
Is it a leg?
Ohh it's a leg
Euugh why does Rudolph need a goddamn- oh there's- right over there's Rudolph's ass
Ohhhhhoohhhohoh
yeeeeegh
Okay. Alright then. Let's go in
Whoo boy
Whooooo boy
Yeah you know it's a bad sign when everything I do needs to be burned on
Whoa boy
I don't even wanna know what this is. Is this PVC piping I'm using as either artery or intestine?(Yes)
Either way it's grotesque and I should feel bad about it
But somehow I only feel empowered by it
Least this one's going a bit smoother than the last one
What is that? What is that? Is that a vacuum? Am I using a vacuum as a substitute?
Why?
Is that even a living thing? Oh god
I- I don't know where this one goes
Oh boy that's not it. The tail? Stop. StOp. STOP
STOOPP
GODDAMN IT I WAS FUCKING- I WAS AT THE FUCKING GODDAMN END
I WAS AT THE FUCKING END!!!
You're gonna do that to me at the end???
WHEN I'M AT THE FUCKING END AFTER I GO THROUGH ALL THE OTHER BULLSHIT
EXCUSE MY PREPUBESCENT VOICE BUT WHAT THE FUUCKKK????
EAT A DICK!!!
Oh it's a- fu- the fucking bolt's in the goddamn leg
OH I'M AN IDIOT
NURSE WHY THE FUCK DID YOU LET ME BE AN IDIOT??
I should just blame you for my problems!!
"Now I just need a conductor and to give it some juice"
that was my fucking fault
Just going up its ass?
Yup that went up its ass!
Alright let's give 'er some juice!
"...now I just have to complete the circuit"
The fuck?
Oh!
*constipated grunting*
"HOONK GLUUUURCK"
oH BOy
"He's up and running! I'd say that's pretty impressive even if it's a bit Frankenstein"
"HOOONK UUUNK"
"He's trying to tell us something!"
"What is it boy? Did somebody fall down the well?"
"You idiot! He can sense where Santa is!"
"We have to follow him!"
How is the elf not questioning why this is horrible?
"But there's something you'll need to do first..."
I mean- the elf doesn't question that this is horrible and that somehow I as a doctor am able to bring a horribly mangled body to life?
Oh my god my voice is just fucking gone
That is all for Amateur Surgeon: Christmas Edition
I don't know what kind of hellhole alternate reality this all takes place in
But it's horrible and they should feel bad about what they're doing here
*Initiate outro music* But either way I had fun
Hope you did too. I hope to have my video- my voice- my voice back to 100% by next video
But we don't know
Maybe it will, maybe it won't
But thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video.
BYE-BYE
Outro music (Crazy La Paint by Minimusicman)